[Applaus]
und wie durch plastik
[Musik]
das ganze wird zuschauer oft werde ich
gefragt moni das schaf ist oder wie
schaffst es immer so unnatürlich glatt
auszusehen was ist dein beauty geheimnis
die antwort ist lustig passen sie mal an
und über ist das klappt sagt wie jogi
löw nach dem brasilien wechseln ich darf
jetzt kein dringender ich werde nicht
nass perlt alles ab sagt munz face
versiegelung screen außerdem ganz
wichtig regelmäßige spelling leider
sollen wir dafür ein mikro plastik wir
nehmen deshalb verwendet unser model
männer die jetzt ein natürliches peeling
mit rollsplitt und glasscherben moniz
gesichts frikassee peeling jetzt nur 960
euro danke melanie das jetzt zum arzt
gehen viel glück melanie kein mikro
plastikmeer im peeling ist ja toll aber
dafür gibt es ohne ende
flüssigkunststoff zum beispiel in
shampoos ja natürlich kunststoff im
stark verbessert die cam barkeit des
hahnes wenn sie oliver jetzt morgens
ihre haare gutes wie schlechtes beispiel
aber ihre lücken hatte lasst es mich
sehen sie mal wie das power weil sie
jetzt die chance nutzen will zu wenig
lustig im shampoo test kommt davon die
usa kanada neuseeland und england haben
micro plastik in kosmetik inzwischen
verboten wäre ja auch schade gerade die
engländer hätten gute kosmetik so
dringend nötig liebe zuschauer lassen
sie sich von der umwelt und idioten
lobby da draußen bitte nicht verrückt
machen das ganze ist eine art
natürlicher kreislauf nur hat und
natürlich einmal duschen befördert bis
zu 100.000 partikel in den
wasserkreislauf die am ende im meer
landen dort von kleinst lebewesen
aufgenommen werden ein leckerbissen für
fische von denen so mancher auf unserem
teller landet auf live avatar und die
fische würzen wir dann auch noch mit
blur disable salz in dem nach neuesten
untersuchungen auch jede menge plastik
ist wann glück ja salz ist überhaupt
nicht gesund jedem weniger salz im salz
desto besser ist ja alles ekelhaft wie
rechten plastik und kein mensch weiß was
es auf dauer mit unserem körper macht er
ist doch wunderbar ich liebe
überraschungen
vielleicht schweißen sehr irgendwann
panini-bilder liebe zuschauer
wenn sie jetzt meine komplette plastik
beauty serie bestellen bekommen sie
gratis diese gourmet plastik habe dazu
endlich micro plastik selber machen
einfach den alten joghurtbecher über die
pflaster reibenden taster plastik
[Applaus]